a represalias anónimas contra cuba' es
la respuesta por las detenciones tras
las protestas del 11 de julio en la isla
la embajada de cuba en parís denunció
que sucede fue atacada causando daños al
edificio pero sin dejar el virus
denunciamos ataque terrorista con
'cócteles molotov' contra nuestra
embajada en parís
responsabilizó al gobierno de eeuu por
sus continuas campañas contra nuestro
país que alienta estas conductas y por
llamados a la violencia con impunidad
desde su territorio
el ministerio de relaciones exteriores
de francia condenó el ataque y abrió una
investigación el embajador de cuba en
francia dijo que el objetivo de estas
agresiones es mostrar la situación de su
país como inestable una potencia de este
mundo por muy poderosa que sea pretenda
imponer a la nación cubana su destino
pretenda imponer un modelo diferente al
que hemos escogido y para seguir
luchando contra ello los cubanos de
adentro y de afuera
seguimos seguiremos defendiendo las
conquistas de la revolución el futuro
que hemos llegado a construir nosotros
mismos perfeccionando lo que debe
perfeccionar perfeccionarse cambiando lo
que debe cambiarse y trabajando con todo
lo cual sin distinción es un llamado a
la paz ya la reconciliación mientras
tanto son enjuiciados 59 manifestantes
que participaron en las protestas del 11
de junio en las que una parte de la
población mostró su descontento con la
escasez de alimentos y de medicinas en
la isla